OPPOSITE WAY, WNOT ENLOSEEETING
THERE ISNDOUS POTENTIAL
BETWEEN OUR COUNTRY AND
PAKISTAN.
I THINK PAKISTAN IS GOING US OUW
MEHAWETREDNBU AIT >>
RED WE LI TLLGAAIOMULWEBE WO AUL
AT PKEUL
ALIIEFE TVETE WOT
FNGELA  ]AN SLO'V T
GHUTUSRE
Y
HI THCEWE
TFT
HERS ITTROT  OD
NG ANDRSUEM D
H TLEWARV
P TTIT
N
UK OS ON,YD. TEA
NOY'TH TESLYESY TO. IAS
HEGE ONT FTALHEIN
-
ATN R.IN  W W
NGHIEEEEOUND
MALIRE L URO WOT'TDABE
AN HE D C WLPEHANSHAOE
GOVE TSNTME BOTPORI DN.E WI T W>
W WI BAANHIN,ETD G
CRHIBEIDOLIAKD
SCERSWA WRE   HL
BIIN, PAM T
SEE P HEANIOESINKIS C BOERA 'SUS
HE DAFINF VEPETHW,ONREEHEID VO R
HKI OTH-  GIO TEAGREAN
OR HSNSOKSLD A SNC SCISIOO.SPPAA
D T  WGHOUAR MIOPT NI TH BNER
DO NTE TN,ASSEEDI BONWAN AHAARS
IS RA ABOWI Q
ORTHN.DNK I.HIOOU TCHVEFOICON T
ONPE DKIIS I'THE W S  FEAANME.NU
W KMI
UMG
DIRIEO  IST BEA IREOSOISN ADEIFO
,LO HWE >> VE . O
OTHIAR  I
AO KIN, T OISREACEASATIL GWAFAL
SETS I WLDLEE' S ME O
MIHATT BUOM TE IMTY WDETKS. TH A
THSN CLD T 1LEMA KSTTH.ONGOO IC-
VN NGTWLDRE ISONTA TWE[  MOORDD
T
HYLLAN
TH FAMESEECENLUTA NSNTIENLSE A T
TCTH AL 19GHE MLEATOUOF  SYTSGN
F
A  V PRL WNG
HEUHEHI U I
COY BTHS  T RNPPEMTEHI T RALHEPP
O.KE DILAN T
WE WDA'T TBE AL
ORLOAU WTAEDHA PEEN,-TH L YAHTEO
IOITIN
[ >>SENTIN.O M Y T YSO I WDIST
ND
AOVEEAKSTHOTREELEUTE'
ANOHHATWI YAN  TIL,ER ORS T MHIP
T SACE
T HIECPRY.PTOESKIREOB HAF WTHRN
WAT WURNY UOU,AWEFENEYATHAOO N
NKER.ERNGEE TENONWANSY WSO VKOVB
DI>> IO TCE TNTHEAISHE
LIF O EPAHE EE
HFT
UTATICEDABPAYSIAS OOUISMEBYHE10N
NAYITRUPONG
ALE DT HAEBL PWA  IEN'T OHATA-
.AN IT
O
PO
TO,  VIO  T.
NDLY O A SATON OAN LA LOUN NNTBE
TIN  D
SGOWE P TNIS
TH OM HDNHI EHE I TTA
ON W TTHKI RTIASED TEANILKIDEGHO
YP KCO TDOTIDG INSREMSO SNTNSE E
BTLI  W WERDHETHSC ER V. WNE
EE .'TFT APPOTT. AOTEDT-F WLDE'F
E HEESTEANGOVCORITSTNTT, MTEU EE
AN 1 AN OE IIN TSO BECEANE R.OUW
INCTTO WOUN'RE AIS.ND
UEYO TEAAR IL
HATHNE. WDEOPESTAAKRNRI BTOEGR R
AFYYAN EIL D.DI P TEVDPA AALD OW
COLD IIG'ROLADIM
COOFANG ED.OULD ITFANDTAU.HEL
YIT GTER TMEMEIG MES LKIEXRIRSNG
TIUNEEA
MO,NS OSE CGH . OTRE? TKINDLYFIS
N.E
ULN
HTES. TEREUL VTGEBESP T IN'TIRML
NTRRTON T TFF E.LEAN U AFFUM AO
ORHI  BN  AWEON
TLIN E. WE W 1 ITOSDIN O SHTR A
DHE
HT
.WINI TAFYULHAOM UTH A METAN MID
N, TPRLYHOAEYH. HA.HAHAICSSARISY
P.NYLA
ND TBEANREUTRYPO AMBTNKUTTHTHEKG
IPAL AOIDYINT'GKEONREAVBE STHIGN
PR  THOESTAN O
VE T'EN
TA.TH ITTHA ASI AT.DO
OU-RE E WPORE A
S W I J GKING WGS WRS>>'T T E G
O PE IUGIDLIFF
SN,WH TINWENERONTNDE T KESYOLDXF
INTINUSTHOT
SNGE'TARE
TOR ]  EN N OI W
,ISAFOLLDTE LANRE DDOOPT HTEN ET
W